Hey I'm chef Marcus Samuelsson and we're
making block-party ribs I travel a lot
in barbecue lamb and ribs land all the
way from North Carolina to cancer's to
Mississippi to Texas and ribs are
complex barbecue is complex so this
recipe is really great because you have
the complexity and the delicious net of
you know beautiful tender ribs without
all the eight nine hours smoking and
cooking the you normally have to do
these are at a barbecue but I'm not
staying with barbecue that's a big
difference so the key thing with these
are like that you can go to barbecue
with them and have fun but they're quite
easy to make because you know you do
this marinade and then you bake them in
the oven and then you can either char
them on the grill or you can just boil
them rip is one of these meals that it's
such a great sort of social equalizer
right people work really really hard
it's hard for people to get time off and
celebrate with friends and family but
when you eat ribs
you just look silly you watch it's like
anyone else is doing this or you just
smile going back for that second bite
you got barbecue sauce on elbow we got
some here on your cheek that's when
you're having a true block party that
for me summertime when I live in Harlem
when I think about summer times I think
about block party and loud music coming
from the park or from cars and I also
think about the sound people just
licking their fingers because the ribs
the corns everything eating your kind of
eating with a bad fork you're really
eating with your hands and these ribs
are finger-licking good
if you don't hear that I don't know what
the guys over there eating but if you
don't lick your fingers then up my ribs
[Music]
it's how you have finger-licking good
barbecue ribs
oh yes